and as mentioned Greece is in a showdown
with its creditors a Greek official says
they will ask for a loan extension
tomorrow but so much damage already done
Greek banks unable to tap investors for
cash bleeding deposits and exhausting
their stash of emergency funds while
they wait for the ECB to throw them a
lifeline well joining us now is renowned
billionaire investor Gruber Ross used to
chairman and CEO of WL Ross who has made
a number of investments in distressed
European banks including Bank of Cyprus
bank of ireland and the greek gyro bank
last summer well we're great to see you
good you see who better this morning so
you have a lot of skin in this game
Wilbur when you hear this news out it
looks as if maybe we might have come to
some sort not an agreement per se but at
least some sort of a light a lifeline
here right or an extension with this
loan agreement what do you want to hear
what do you want to see get done well I
think a compromise of some sort needs to
be made the unfortunate thing is this is
being negotiated in the news media
rather than in the conference room and
that makes it harder for people to
modify their positions after you've said
800 times I won't do this it's a little
hard to go do it right I mean and you
know you would expect though I mean
Wilbur mean as in all negotiations they
are played out in both the media sure
and also privately so this new is about
the loan agreement though does that give
you is that make you more positive well
it does because it's a recognition on
the part of Greece that it does need the
money so that's good the deadline for
that as I understand it is sometime this
week perhaps as latest friday so there's
so little bit of time for people to go
back and forth I think the amount of the
loan is not going to be the big problem
and probably the duration doesn't make
that much difference I think the key
things will be what other conditions are
appended to it what do they do about
rehiring government workers what do they
do about the minimum wage all the
societal reforms
and how much of a primary budget surplus
will grease commit to is it goodness
there too there is but Merkel and
company I mean are they being too hard
on Greece I mean you know are some of
these reforms they sound pretty
reasonable to me right I mean raising
minimum wage at a time when unemployment
is skyrocketing and at the same time
peoples incomes are going down I mean
seems like a reasonable ver yeah I think
it isn't so much a question of what's
reasonable but here you have Ireland who
lived up very faithfully to all the
elements of their bailout which were
every bit as severe as the conditions
imposed reason then you have waiting in
the wings portugal possibly italy 0
going to be very eager to see to how far
can grease gets so you have those
complications on the EU side as well as
mrs. Merkel's complication with their
own voters right with what's going on in
Germany and then on the Greek side you
have tsipras ran against the troika
against the bailout how far can he get
so it's really chances of an exit you
don't think I don't think so i think
everybody understands that's not a good
idea from anyone's point of view okay so
you've bet big on on on this crisis well
not as big as we're be prepared to do
well what are you prepared to do well i
think that once we get out of the non
trading period we're in a period right
now where we not permitted to buy
yourself because the banks have it
reported their year-end earnings so
there's no action we can take right
today but at the prices where things are
trading assuming i'm right that there
will be a deal i think it's very
attractive okay so very so europe is
very attractive to you so you've already
gone into ireland you got into greece
and in cyprus so what's the next country
for Wilbur Ross are you preparing
something are you are you are you
putting together a group with it within
Europe we're actually looking at
something a little different which is
another segment Europe has lots of banks
and
fact is more dependent on banks than the
US but they don't have the specialty
finance companies like we have here a
few of them are starting to be organized
and we're looking very much at that
sector as a kind of supplement to the
conventional bank system can you give me
some examples like what do you mean by
specialty well there are specialized
lenders in the UK that just lend a small
and medium enterprises for example there
are specialized mortgage lenders who
just do build to that mortgages so
they're starting to have these very
specific entities form but it's early
days but could we see something done by
you in 12 months well I hate to put
limits on time on the self because you
never know how long something will take
but what we're actively looking at
things like that